[Applause]
and finally new rule this dangerous idea
that has taken root in America that
something is true merely because you
want to believe it's true has got to
go
I I have spent an awful lot of time on
this show in the pre-trump and the then
the Trump presidency years trying to
convince people that this man would
never concede losing an election no
matter what the truth was
and what made me so sure of that was
that America had become a place where
truth no longer mattered it was all
about whether it felt right in your gut
Donald Trump lost to Joe Biden I can't
be right that's what many of his fans
said and still do anytime an issue
didn't go their way the response would
be crisis actors that's what that was
crisis
actors false flag operations the Deep
State when the right does this we call
it conspiracy theories and rightly so
when the left does it we call it
emotional
truth which brings me to Hassan Minaj
the comedian who answers the question
what if Jesse Smet did stand
[Applause]
up if you missed it the New Yorker
originally ran a comprehensive expose
about how many of the stories Mr Minaj
tells in his act to elicit sympathy for
himself as a Muslim and a person of
color are completely made up now let's
pause here to acknowledge that Muslims
and people of color in America have of
course faced prejudice and
discrimination and this country has a
racial history that is nothing short of
Despicable and some of it continues to
this day the question I'm always asking
is where exactly are we with this now
because it's not as good as the right
says it is and I think it's also not as
bad as the left says but if you have to
fabricate the stories of your
mistreatment isn't that itself a comment
on where we are
[Applause]
now one of Mr Minaj's stories is about a
white girl he asked to the prom who
spurned him on the the big day when her
parents didn't want pictures taken with
the brown boy except it never happened
then there was the time the FBI hunted
him down as a suspected terrorist and
threw him against the hood of a car
except for the part where they didn't do
that at all the New Yorker writer who
interviewed Minaj asks does it matter
that neither of those things really
happened
yes yes it does matter it does matter
if if you want to speak truth to power
I'm going to go out on a limb here and
say you have to include the truth
part because he's done this before with
me accusing me of saying Muslims should
be put in internment camps something
I've never come close to thinking little
alone saying and it's an odd thing to
claim given that this show is you know
recorded with cameras in
audience so I ask you a guy saying he
saw me saying round up the Muslims on TV
even though I never did how is that
different than this guy and I watched in
Jersey City New Jersey where thousands
and thousands of people were cheering as
that building was coming
down this country needs to make a grand
bargain bull is bad no matter
who says it or what you call
it Manar says the emotional truth is
first the factual truth is secondary
that's the part of the Zeitgeist he has
captured that it's all about getting to
the truth man and what better way to do
that than by
lying
I think the younger Generations have a
real problem with wanting to build their
identity around being a victim they want
to have racism to fight not fight racism
have racism to fight so badly that when
it's not there they make it up and
there's enough real racism in the world
that making up more doesn't
help Minaj told the New Yorker that his
actual life was too dull to provide
juicy material for his
acts isn't that a good
thing he seems to literally feel cheated
by progress the
pro the progress that has denied him any
good stories about being oppressed by
the man dude America is far from the
worst you're a Muslim married to a Hindu
if you were living in India she'd have
to murder you
and that prom date that he talks about
he didn't disguise her identity very
well and now she has had to deal with
death threats and doxing there are
consequences to lying and funny Side
Story you know who she married another
Indian
guy hearing that even Minaj himself must
know man if people don't like you now
it's probably not because you're a
person of color it's because you're
shady